Українські ТЕС дають найдорожчу електроенергію
у світі, а робота самих теплоелектростанцій -
найбільш неефективна у світі.
Так стверджують британські аналітики
з незалежного аналітичного центру "Carbon Tracker"
у своєму звіті "Powering down coal".
Згідно зі звітом "Powering down coal",
середній тариф для українських ТЕС за мегават-годину
становить 70 доларів.
Тобто в рейтингу найдорожчої теплової генерації,
як видно на цьому графіку, Україна - беззаперечний антилідер
і значно перевищує показники ЄС, Південної Кореї та Японії.
Найменші ж експлуатаційні видатки для ТЕС -
в Індонезії - майже удвічі менші, ніж в Україні.
Опитані DW експерти також підтверджують, що
ціна електроенергії з українських ТЕС на 30-40% вища,
ніж у ЄС і майже на 75% вища, ніж у Росії.
Одна з головних причин - фактична монополізація ринку вугілля.
Понад 80% українського вугілля видобуває
найбільший енергетичний холдинг України - ДТЕК
мільярдера Ріната Ахметова. Йому ж належить і
абсолютна більшість українських ТЕС.
ДТЕК зацікавлений якомога більше свого вугілля
з собівартістю 1200-1300 гривень за тонну
спалювати на своїх же ТЕС за більш ніж удвічі вищою ціною,
вирахуваною за формулою "Роттердам+", стверджує
голова Асоціації споживачів енергетики та комунальних послуг Андрій Герус.
За цією схемою, щоб визначити вартість вугілля
для українських ТЕС, береться ціна вугілля в порту
нідерландського Роттердама плюс витрати на умовну доставку в Україну.
При цьому незалежно від того, звідки реально
постачається вугілля й чи відповідає воно якісним стандартам - таким, як у Роттердамі.
Окрім того, українські вугільні електростанції
неефективні й дорогі через високі витрати палива,
бо власники приватних українських ТЕС
не виконують інвестиційні зобов’язання,
які брали під час приватизації, тобто не проводять
належну реконструкцію й модернізацію станцій.
Хоча кошти на це закладено в тарифах
на електроенергію як для промисловості, так і для населення.
Для споживачів вартість електроенергії в останні роки
фактично зросла на 300%.
За словами директора НАБУ Артема Ситника,
через скандальну формулу "Роттердам+"
українці вже переплатили за електрику 15 мільярдів гривень.
Ведеться розслідування. Політики заявляють, що
ця формула корупційна і неприйнятна, але вона продовжує діяти.
Українські ТЕС справді найбільш неефективні у світі
й виробляють найдорожчу електроенергію.
Через схему "Роттердам+" вартість вугілля в Україні
нині вища, ніж у державах, де вугілля взагалі
не видобувається, приміром, в Японії.
Фактична монополізація вугільного ринку
енергохолдингом ДТЕК і відсутність конкуренції
не сприяють ефективності українських ТЕС.
Більшість із них морально і фізично застарілі.
Вугільна генерація в Україні створювалася
понад півстоліття тому, і з того часу з неї лише
витискали по максимуму зиск без належних капіталовкладень.